you kind of been keeping like your
circle tighter and I'm kind of notice
that in your video that's my life and
filming it yeah it's because there was
such a huge mental shift with me where
when you're surviving to be like a
youtuber views and numbers and followers
and subscribers are so important so
everything you're doing is kind of
driven by is this going to get me more
subscribers I need to clap because that
means more people are gonna see me and I
genuinely just don't give a [ __ ] about
that I care about creating stuff I'm
very proud of and excited about and I
just kind of made a rule for myself
where if you're only in my life when the
cameras are on I can't have that in my
life right now you know yeah there's
nothing wrong with collabing there's
nothing wrong with having business
relationships but I'm just a sensitive
little [ __ ] and I need some old support
in my life yeah yeah every time we
interviewed david dobrik there's people
asking people at yelling at me saying
why don't you ask him about Gaby people
want problems so badly that's the thing
is the internet will just try to look
for conspiracies I've heard that I'm the
reason they broke up like that's
occurring no it's just people have
different goals and they do different
things and like I said I I like having
friendship circles where we're just like
hanging and I don't need the pressure of
filming and cameras and that that's what
they do a lot like I said that's okay
you can have collaborative relationships
but that's just not your thing yeah we
don't hate each other like he was one of
the first people that was like liking
tweets about me being chopped to when I
put out honest and on course it was
liking tweets about that and like if I
have a question about cars like I'll
text them you know yeah people just want
people want drama so bad
I posted a video like clearing up all
the drama and like I texted him first
and sent it to him and said is this okay
he's like yeah and one time he was going
to answer a question and a QA and send
it to me and said is it cool if I say
this and it I'm not saying and I don't
know how many more times like people
have to say it like it's fine it is cool
though cuz I feel like you guys are a
part of kind of this one wave of YouTube
with what everyone was
the fire yeah invention Wow I'm so glad
that came out of my mouth I just made it
up didn't know if I was gonna work words
mouths words it but it's like everyone
from that wave who like stuck to it has
kind of carved their own path and like
made their own Lane it's totally okay to
do that and I think it's important for
everyone to understand that in life
people just grow apart and that doesn't
mean that something awful is going on
it's just like I need to be focusing my
energy in the studio on writing working
on my fitness working on my mental
health and it doesn't leave a lot of
time for like like the antics and stuff
and I'm also a very anxious person and I
need a lot of alone time and I don't
like you know being startled it was a
very high anxiety situation and it's not
for everyone it's the same as I don't
really talk to my best friends from high
school yeah and it's not because I hate
them it's because we're different yeah
no yes okay million-dollar question is
once you do you become a full-fledged
mainstream artist II I love the way well
I loved the wind in that sentence were
you we both know like I already told you
but when that happens we'll YouTube
still be your day job where you still do
you think you're still wanna appreciate
that content and I think it's gonna be
the content sort of like I'm posting now
where it's just if I'm doing something I
like to film it where as opposed to what
I used to do which is I need a good idea
that's gonna go viral
even my videos that do really well now
like the faking Coachella video that was
just something that I was excited to do
I don't do it going into it like this
video is gonna be great because it's
trendy right now and you know people
love faking trips I did it because I
thought it'd be funny to do yeah so
that's just gonna be what it is you know
if I'm on tour my videos are gonna be
stuff that I'm doing on tour if I'm in
the studio all the time I'll just be
showing more behind the scenes of the
studio and I will also be doing you know
the regular vlog II suffer it's like hey
guys gotta clean my car I'm a mask
watch it original marbles approach
underway like she's doing oh I wish
honestly yeah she that is a pretty good
diversion I never really thought about
it that way but for sure she's just like
the owner thing I'm gonna dull I got my
house I got my dogs watch Mila yeah yeah
I might for you yeah it's way easier I'm
a more authentic in myself
yeah now that you know the EP is out
you're still hanging with the YouTube
videos what's the next step for you is
it getting to that album as a tour
oh yeah I have I was actually supposed
to put an album out when I put the EP
out and the album's pretty much finished
I have a few more tweaks and one more
track to record but the album for sure
building a real solid music team around
me because right now like I'm Roman free
do it do it because I'm working on like
the proper promotion because like - Amir
had zero promotion yeah except for what
I was posting so working on promotion
and then would love to tour that's the
most exciting dream like I want to open
for panic you know I want to just be a
working musician and I don't care what
the money looks like right away because
you know opener spots don't really get
anything but I'm just trying to open for
one of my favorite bands girl is coming
justice for that Tanner cotton
performance I didn't on it honestly
[Music]
[Applause]